okay guys in case you haven't heard yet
the absolute best player in the entire
overwatch league just up and quit to
play valor n't Sinatra left behind an
established league backed by one of the
biggest publishers out there not to
mention a substantial paycheck to play
in an eSports scene that doesn't even
exist yet and yeah while this is only
good for valor n't the implications for
the future of the overwatch league are
terrible we should be worried about the
o WL at this point very worried
all right guys before we go any further
don't forget if you haven't subscribed
to the score eSports YouTube channel yet
what are you waiting for we produce
content each and every day six to seven
days a week 365 Cove adorno Kovan so go
ahead and click that Bell
okay so Sinatra real name Jae Hwan I'm
willing to bet even if you don't give a
damn about the overwatch League you
might have heard of this guy last year
he demolished the overwatch League with
his team the San Francisco shocked and
took home the MVP for the entire season
not to mention winning overwatch World
Cup with Team USA
I mean look there is a reason we
nominated him for the score eSports
Player of the Year award in 2019 the
thing that I like about Sinatra like for
this award as a nominee is he has that
cool redemption story as well you know
he started off as like a problematically
toxic player and he made a complete
switch over and he's a leader and
Tuesday he dropped an eSports classic a
hastily written twit longer announcing
his retirement from the overwatch League
at the age of 20 as for exactly why well
in his twit longer he said quote
straight up just lost passion for the
game I don't know what the real killer
was for me but maybe it was 2 to 2 lakh
maybe it was bands I'm not sure I just
know it was hard for me to log on to
play and I didn't have fun in scrims
slash ranked games at all anymore
end quote I think like 1 2 2 2 came I
definitely killed it for me because like
the queue times are like hours long I
couldn't [ __ ] play it I hear I wanted
some times like everything just sucked
about it and then banning like here to
do that [ __ ] is so annoying like I like
having one minute and like for a little
bit at least like a month or something
and then figuring it out and then like
getting or like perfecting it but like
right now the metas changing every
[ __ ] week
it's like too much anyways just hours
after announcing that he was retiring
from overwatch League it became official
he was joining sentinels as part of
their valor in team a team by the way
that might just be the weirdest lineup
of misfit FPS players I've ever seen I
mean you've got the best overwatch
player in the world paired with an apex
competitor of veteran CSKA Opera in the
form of Shazam and a young csgo player
SiC who's been up and down with rosters
like misfits and complexity it's an
ambitious crossover but let's get back
to the Sinatra news this is just so bad
for the o WL I mean they just lost the
Michael Jordan of their league to a game
in closed beta a game that right now has
basically no eSports scene to speak of
and won't have a legitimate organized
league structure for some time to come
in fact Riot Games has overtly stated
that they don't want to jump into a
fully franchise League like o WL did
they want to let the scene develop
organically with third-party tournaments
kind of like what they did with League
of Legends in the early days the
stability of the overwatch League the
infrastructure of a team operated by an
NBA owner and the juicy paycheck that
Sinatra was pulling down none of it
could keep this kid from jumping ship
and it's not just that Sinatra is the
best in the game either the other thing
that makes him so valuable is that he is
a marketable star and God knows the o WL
struggled to create the kind of stars
that sell jerseys put butts in seats and
he hear guys make lifelong fans but
Sinatra was that guy
he had a great story going from a toxic
kid to a polished star he had a popular
clothing line that sold out he was on
Jimmy Fallon representing the brand you
get the idea congratulations guys I
appreciate it thanks so much for coming
on Jason after one and Matthew super
delicious and look guys one superstar
coming or going is not gonna make or
break an eSport or an esports league but
if you've ever heard the expression
canary in a coalmine well this is one
the latest of many over the last year or
so there's just been so many cracks
appearing in the o WL from allegations
of you bahding to talk of declining
viewership on YouTube to the departure
of Nate Mann's are for fortnight to the
mass exodus of talent we saw at the
beginning of the year it's just been one
bad headline after another for the
overwatch league and if you need a
refresher on any of that well as far as
the talent goes in January of this year
Monte Cristo Doha Semler Malik Forte and
Chris Puckett all left the overwatch
League
as for their reasons they cited problems
with creative differences problems with
the game itself and problems with the
salary they were being offered about a
year ago Natan answer the Commissioner
of the Oh WL and a man that Monte Cristo
described as the linchpin to
understanding the games audience left
for epic games this was if you remember
generally regarded as a pretty worrying
sign for the eSports side of overwatch
as far as the viewbotting stuff goes
well in May of last year Kotaku
published a report that alleged that the
overwatch League may have seriously been
inflating their viewership numbers by
having streams that autoplay the game's
embedded on hundreds of websites and I'm
not even gonna mention the problems with
overwatch contenders the merchandise
Fiasco's or the unrealistic expectations
when it comes to filling stadiums for
overwatch League regular-season games
look the overwatch league is dying is
maybe a bit of a meme at this point but
that doesn't mean it isn't happening if
we start seeing more top-line talent
JumpShip for valor interests about
anything else we might have to start
counting the nails in the coffin here it
would surprise me if watch League
players
quit the game it wouldn't surprise me I
saw something missing and now I know for
a fact that I have a handful of people
I'm leaving
no well Sinatra leaving might be
horrible news for overwatch eSports it's
pretty damn encouraging 4-valent
obviously at this point every retired
pro tier 2 player streamer have declared
themselves of valor --nt pro but there's
a big difference between all of that and
the best overwatch player in the world I
mean with all due respect to all of
those legitimately talented and very
determined csgo pros who are trying to
make a go of it valiant the reality is
we probably won't be talking much about
them come to years when the Valor and
eSports scene really gets going I've
said it in a past video but the future
of the Balor and eSports scene are not
gonna be retired csgo players guys with
all due respect to a ZK and he co and
anybody else the real future eSport
stars of the
game of Valor --nt are 15 years old
right now and they're gonna be
demolishing these names we already know
in a couple years but Sinatra is a
totally different conversation he's at
the top of his game the peak of his
prowess and he did use to play
counter-strike so we know he has the
ability to transition games successfully
he's also a DPS player known for his aim
his movement and his communication so if
he wants to hit the reset button at age
20 he can probably do it and still be
successful and what an unprecedented
transition that would be can you imagine
the very best player in one major
eSports transitioning and becoming
potentially among the very best players
in another major eSport it's like if
faker went to dota or if simple decided
he wanted to compete in Rainbow six
siege it's like if Michael Jordan played
baseball but was actually good at it
obviously at this point we don't know
just how successful Sinatra's move will
be but I do know one thing he is better
positioned than just about anyone I can
think of to make the Valor and pro meme
reality I've got some shadow comics I
don't know if you know the shadow he's a
pulp hero from like the 30s and the 20s
kind of like a proto Batman but with
guns interesting story about the Phantom
movie I went to see it in theaters when
I was a kid all right and when you I
guess maybe it was opening weekend or
something but they had some promotion
well you got a phantom ring here this
skull he has a skull ring with powers
it's really cool
and you got a phantom ring and as a kid
I got the ring in the movie theater put
it on watch the movie I couldn't get it
off my finger couldn't get it off my
finger turned like Lulu and I had to go
to the hospital and they had to put like
some industrial-strength lube on it to
get it off and they threw out the ring
and even got to keep the magic phantom
ring it's disappointing